[Music]
so far apple or okay with videos okay a
party started
my nemesis assaulted or equal on each
tile then are all the niches Cassie to
do
[Music]
Manami Sanjeev Laos
so Susie stop Roxy oh now a specialist a
new phenomena pororoca condo in Saco des
Voges sulfonamides longer de modo
nama zhonya a pororoca UNAMI dado on
phenomena Brazil tone Malaysia Metro
scuba cozy agua even Amazon dodo
co-presenter do you / kahindo distances
in imagine Avis essentially Sofia's on
dismiss low Gazoo mondo mondo di
pororoca ray totalmente diferente de
Seine la Seine Aleta so fond o Umar
aguas Oh God delightful - ah mais God
Ohio
Anita Matos PI's dancin with on a leash
no consent a beautiful trousseau modern
opera Roca alapanai berea muchos Oh Tom
eh eh Polly tiendas de Mayo Metro
Wanda's a TDI quattro Metro suffice
zoda's avoid forties yale ave e manchu
ha de agua eh team with stroke espouse
Bobo's madoka me sufen opera rock yahoo
supreme only a hitch palette on open
taught me to each Makwana to desert for
Houston by RB Amadou planet he stood
firm all the approach committee note II
feel pain discrete evil they call this
stretch of Lenore Shore the seven mile
miracle
there's a world-class surf break every
hundred or so yards we rescue up to a
thousand people a year definitely one of
the most dangerous stretches of beaches
in the world
my name is Tao Hanuman and I've been a
lifeguard for 14 years here on the North
Shore I work here at a kite beach park
it's the home of the surf break Banzai
Pipeline which is a very dangerous wave
that breaks in very shallow water
it's such a critical wave that if you
fall down the chances of getting injured
of hitting the reef is very high even
when it's really small we have very
strong powerful rip currents it's very
easy to get swept out in the rip current
and not be able to make it back to shore
just yesterday the lifeguards made about
20 rescues
knowing that the possibility of drowning
is very real you know especially in
large surf we all train my training
consists of running the beach
of swimming anything basically in my
area we do mock rescues if the surf is
big I'll tell one of my partners hey go
go out and get pounded in the surf I'll
come get you with the rescue tube so
he'll go out and you know he's taking
waves on the head and you know see how
fast we can get to them
whatever the oceans gonna do if someone
needs help and you have to go get that
person you got to be ready to do that
you're putting yourself in a very risky
situation but knowing that your partner
has your back there's it builds a strong
sense of camaraderie we have a good
morale between us all we do this job for
the love of the job amazing even if you
can save another person's life it's very
rewarding for sure to be able to be
doing science while you're out there on
the surfboard surfing down the face of
the wave it's just such a fleeting
moment it's incredible to actually be
able to do it
smartphone is a surfboard fit you clip
it on the bottom of your board you go
out for your surf session it has
technology that measures ocean pH
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they are shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we have detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they are just not
deployed at the coast bingo
smart fin can fill that gap collecting
oceanic data is a very time-consuming
expensive process this is like you just
need to know how to surf the data moves
from your fin to your phone via
bluetooth and then from your phone it
goes up to our servers where everything
is processed I had to develop sensors
that don't affect the surfboard nobody's
gonna surf a fin that is not a standard
foil aside from that LED right there is
blinking that tells you that there's
like some sort of technology there you
wouldn't know the difference so we've
got a test tank set up now
and we're just trying to look at the
precision and accuracy of the instrument
itself things are looking pretty
promising as a scientist it's pretty
exciting to be able to get data over
these different time and space scales I
mean the fact that you can go out and
surf and contribute to understanding
what's actually happening out there is
incredible
I'm not a surfer I know nothing about
surfing I know I looked like a surfer
but um I'm not surfers are very
influential and care deeply about the
environment and want to be talking about
it
so smartphone is just a tool to do that
in a more concrete way there's so many
reasons why I do what I do I love
surfing and I love helping people I
think if everybody found what they love
to do what they were designed to do and
use that gift to help others there's a
world would look so different
[Music]
my name is Lambert Lowe and I'm a surf
instructor I was living in Hawaii living
the dream teaching surfing to
billionaires and celebrities at the end
of the day something was missing and I
knew in my heart that I needed to come
back to where it all started I grew up
in California the ocean was where I felt
the most connected but came back and
started a nonprofit called the mix
Academy
[Music]
one of the things that come out of the
mix Academy is this surf school and I
brought that gift of surfing here with
some of the people that need the most
smiles my current class consists of a
refugee from North Korea Nathan a
nine-year-old who is visually impaired
and Shannon a veteran going through
alcoholism
school of the misfits is a place where
you can belong on land everyone looks at
us a little differently but when you're
in the water the water washes all that
off surfing like life is full of ups and
downs there's waves that are coming you
can't stop that from coming pains gonna
come what you can't control is yourself
and how you're gonna react
you can choose to paddle for it embrace
it adapt to it and enjoy the ride or
this waves gonna come and it's gonna
knock you out and it's gonna like you
out catching the wave was a great
feeling
helping others catch their first wave is
a greater feeling to watch that smile
just ear to ear and knowing that yeah
that's gonna change someone's life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Montana is a landlocked state it blows
my mind every day but there is waves in
the river and you can surf them on
surfboards just like you would in the
ocean we have a huge surf culture here
in Missoula my name is Kevin Ben Hart
Brown I go by KB and I own strong water
Mountain surf company we are the
original Mountain surf shop and still
the only surf shop in the state of
Montana
I mean it's cowboy country here surfing
is in my soul from my very first
earliest memories at the age of 3 is
visiting my grandparents in San Diego
and seen surfing in the ocean and for
whatever reason I've been kind of
searching for surfing my whole life and
I'm happy to be here in Missoula Montana
and tapped into river surfing in the
river it's a standing wave so the wave
is essentially stationary you're going
back and forth across the wave but the
wave is kind of in one place the water's
coming at you it's pretty amazing
you know we've built a really strong
River surf community here there's just a
ton of support and good vibes and good
energy this whole connection with nature
correlates directly with kind of that
same vibe that you get in the ocean not
a lot of people know about River surfing
but there's River surfing communities
popping up everywhere and it's just
starting to explode for me personally
it's about doing what people don't think
you can do and proving that you can do
it and you know just getting out and
having a good time sharing the sport
it's exciting and fun to be on this
whole new frontier